>> Laura: YOU HAVE BEEN WATCHING
THE SHOW, YOU KNOW THAT COLLEGE
CAMPUSES ARE WORSE THAN EVER
WHEN IT COMES TO FREE EXPRESSION
AND REAL TOLERANCE, ESPECIALLY
THE TOLERANCE FOR VIEWS THAT ARE
RIGHT TO LIFE.
WELL, TAKE THIS EXCHANGE BETWEEN
A STUDENT AT BOSTON COLLEGE AND
KRISTIN HAWKINS.
OF STUDENTS FOR LIFE.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT THE
CHILDREN THAT ARE APPREHENDED AT
THE BORDER THAT ARE IN U.S.
GOVERNMENT CARE, DO YOU THINK,
LIKE, BABIES WHO ARE GOING TO
DIE SHOULD BE RESUSCITATED AND
GIVEN CARE?
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT, LIKE, A
BABY WHO'S BORN ALIVE DURING
ABORTION AT PLANT PARENTHOOD
SHOULD GET CARE?
>> NO.
>> Laura: JOINING ME IS KRISTIN
HAWKINS.
YOU TRAVEL THE COUNTRY VISITING
COLLEGE CAMPUSES TALKING TO
STUDENTS.
YOU REALLY KIND OF POINTED OUT
THE, YOU KNOW, ILLOGICAL
THINKING IS ONE THING.
IT'S SAD, IT'S FUNNY IN A WAY
BUT VERY SAD.
WHAT HAPPENED NEXT AFTER THAT?
>> I ACTUALLY ASKED HER WHY SHE
DIDN'T BELIEVE THAT BABIES WHO
ARE BORN ALIVE DURING ABORTION
SHOULD ABE LOUED TO LIVE.
SHE SAID WE'VE DETERMINED IT'S
NOT A BABY.
THEN SHE WENT ON TO SAY I KNOW
YOU SAID SCIENCE, BUT.
SHE POINTED OUT THE COGNITIVE
DEFICIT YOU SEE COLLEGE
CAMPUSES, I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
OR NOT I CHANGED HER MIND BUT
SHE CERTAINLY CHANGED THE MINDS
OF A LOT OF PRO-CHOICE STUDENTS
WHO CAME TO THE EVENT TO PROTEST
ME I GOT TO SEE THEIR EYES LIGHT
UP WHEN SHE POINTED OUT THE
HYPOCRISY.
>> Laura: YOU ASKED ABOUT
CHILDREN AT THE BORDER SHOULD
THEY BE HELPED SHOULD THEY BE
CARED FOR, INFANTS, YES A BABY
WHO IS BORN, DESPITE AN ATTEMPT
TO ABORT THE BABY, NO.
IT'S WE FLEKTIVE, NOT LIKE --
REFLECTIVE.
>> RIGHT.
THIS IS EXACTLY, REPEATING THE
TALKING POINTS THAT THEY HEAR.
WHEN IT COMES OUT OF THEIR MOUTH
AND YOU FORCE THE OTHER SIDE TO
ACTUALLY SAY WHAT IT IS, THEY'RE
ADVOCATING FOR, IT CHANGES THE
MINDS OF EVERYONE LISTENING
UNTIL THEY REALIZE, THIS DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE.
THIS IS ILLOGICAL.
YOUR HUMANITY SHOULDN'T BE
DETERMINED BY THE LOCATION OF
YOUR DELIVERY ROOM.
>> Laura: ISN'T THIS WHAT
HAPPENED, YOU WERE AT UCLA
CAMPUS ABOUT A YEAR AGO, TELL US
ABOUT THAT.
>> YES, I'VE BEEN TO UCLA,
BERKELEY, HARVARD, PRINCETON,
DORT MOUTH.
>> Laura: GOOD FOR YOU.
>> WE HAVE THIS CONVERSATION,
THE LIES OF FEM NIRNT POWER.
I TELL WOMEN, YOU ARE BEING LIED
TO BY THE ABORTION LOBBY THAT
TELLS YOU YOU HAVE TO PAY
SOMEBODY ELSE TO COMMIT AN ACT
OF VIOLENCE AGAINST SOMEBODY
WEAKER THAN YOU IN ORDER FOR YOU
TO LIVE YOUR LIFE AS YOU SEE
FIT.
THAT'S ANTI-FEMINIST.
>> Laura: WHAT IS THE REACTION,
IS THERE -- I MEAN, YOU'RE BRAVE
TO BE DOING THIS.
YOU'RE A BRAVE PERSON.
I WANT TO SALUTE YOU.
I THINK A LOT OF YOUNG WOMEN, I
SAY THIS ON THE RADIO SHOW, WHEN
YOU'RE IN YOUR 20s, IT WASN'T AN
ISSUE.
BUT NOW, WITH THE HELP OF
SCIENCE, DIGITAL, YOU KNOW, THE
SCIENCE TECHNIQUES, YOU CAN SEE,
NOW WE WERE SPEAKING AS FORMER
EMBRYO, WE ALL WERE.
>> RIGHT.
AND THE GOOD NEWS IS, LAURA, THE
MAJORITY OF OUR GENERATION ARE
PRO-LIFE.
WE'RE THE LARGEST VOTING BLOCK
IN AMERICA.
AND WE REJECT THE LIES OF THE
ABORTION INDUSTRY.
>> Laura: DID YOU SEE
"UNPLANNED".
>> YES, WE SENT THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS, WE HAD A BABY SIFD IN
INDIANA, SHE SAW UNPLANNED,
PRAYED IN FRONT OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND SAVED THE LIFE OF
A CHILD.
>> Laura: OH MY GOSH.